en los últimos vídeos hablamos acerca de
la diferencia entre el valor libro y el
valor de mercado del capital de una
compañía y en este ejemplo esta es una
especie de institución financiera y
estos son sus activos y al menos en sus
libros tienen que poseer un billón de
pesos de bonos del gobierno 10 billones
de bonos corporativos con una
calificación muy alta de triple-a son
préstamos a empresas que casi
seguramente van a pagar sus deudas y 10
billones de hipotecas comerciales por
ejemplo préstamos a personas para que
construyan o compren un edificio de
oficinas y después nos enfocamos en este
activo verde sede o residenciales y
expliqué lo que son seguridades
derivadas que provienen de títulos de
garantía hipotecaria los cuales son un
bonche de hipotecas agrupadas y nos
enfocamos en esto porque este es el
meollo del asunto en el que todo el
mundo se ha estado enfocando desde que
empezó la crisis del crédito aunque esto
es sólo la primera ola o sea esto es lo
que se ha deteriorado por el momento los
precios de las casas han bajado y es
todas estas personas con préstamos de
baja documentación en donde puedes
inventar tu ingreso y obtener un
préstamo por un millón de pesos sin nada
que lo respalde bien esta fue la primera
ola pero si la economía se pone muy mal
muchas de estas hipotecas comerciales
van a empezar a verse igual de mal hoy
en la mañana leí un artículo que dice
que por todas las broncas en el sistema
financiero causadas por los deseos
residenciales hay mucha oferta comercial
y eso está preocupando muchísimo a los
dueños de las hipotecas comerciales pero
bueno no hay que enfocarnos en esto
regresando al tema principal este banco
tiene un activo muy poco confiable y eso
nos deja inseguros acerca de cuánto vale
su capital si realmente valiera este
activo 4 billones entonces tendríamos 3
millones de capital porque los activos
sumarían 26 billones y los pasivos
sumarían 23 billones y los activos menos
los pasivos son el capital o sea 26
billones menos 23 millones es igual a 3
billones y bueno después te dio un
ejemplo de qué pasaría si el mercado de
valores
dando un valor de 1.5 billones a ese
capital y la forma en que se calculaba
esto es ver que action tiene un valor de
mercado de 3 pesos y hay medio millón de
acciones entonces los multiplicamos y
nos da 1.5 billones pero qué pasaría si
el mercado valores dice que este capital
sólo vale 1.5 billones como en el
ejemplo lo que está diciendo
esencialmente es que esté activo vale
1.5 billones menos
quería mencionar eso porque un montón de
personas se confunden entre el valor
libro y el valor de mercado pero ahora
pensemos por qué nos importa esto porque
está hank paulson y george bush y al
parecer todos los demás tan asustados
bueno este es un solo banco y te lo es
todos estos cds valen 0 cuál es el
problema si todos estos valen 0 este
banco se declara en la bancarrota y el
asunto se resuelve con el proceso de la
bancarrota puede ser un vídeo acerca de
cómo funciona este proceso o hay otro
escenario en el que los deseos no valen
cero sino que valen realmente 4 billones
mientras estas personas siguen prestando
su dinero todo estará muy bien ese es el
meollo del asunto si las personas
seguirán prestando su dinero entonces
los préstamos corporativos o préstamos a
corporaciones y bancos van a ver la
mayoría de los préstamos a los que
estamos acostumbrados en la vida
cotidiana como las hipotecas tienen un
periodo fijo 30 años digamos y al final
de ese periodo has pagado todos los
intereses y has pagado completamente el
préstamo los bonos corporativos tienden
diferentes por lo general se van pagando
solo los intereses a lo largo del
periodo y hasta el final tienes que
pagar el capital completo solo algunas
veces se paga el capital en medio del
periodo pero bueno a ver aquí digamos
tomemos este préstamo
y digamos que tienen una tasa de interés
del 7% y un periodo de no seríamos tres
meses
aquí tres meses
eso dice que esta persona te da 10
millones de pesos y cada año le pagas el
7% tal vez le pagas cada mes
aproximadamente en una doceava parte
osea éstas no son ningunas cuentas
exactas pero bueno o sea de hecho le
pagas punto 07 a la potencia un doceavo
y al final de este período de tres meses
le vas a pagar los 10 billones puedes
decir que esta es una forma muy extraña
de financiar te porque cada tres meses
tienes que encontrar otro préstamo y
pues eso es completamente cierto pero en
un ambiente de crédito normal la mayoría
de las empresas dicen ok te presto 10
billones de pesos por tres meses con una
tasa de intereses anual del 7% y después
de los tres meses muchas veces renuevan
el préstamo o puedes encontrar
fácilmente a alguien más que te preste
ese dinero con más o menos los mismos
condiciones y pagar el préstamo anterior
con el nuevo préstamo se podría decir
que estamos renovando los préstamos
el banco consigue de una forma u otra
nuevos préstamos que sustituyen a los
anteriores
algo que podría estar pasando aquí es
que tienes estos préstamos a corto plazo
y cuando es hora de renovar los el banco
o quien te haya prestado ese dinero dice
ya no estoy tan segura porque número uno
el precio de sus acciones se ha ido
hasta el fondo y bueno tal vez muchos de
estos fondos de cobertura han hecho
mejor su tarea que yo y el banco los
querían los préstamos y las agencias de
calificación y tal vez están viendo que
algo está muy chueco y yo sé que pues
tienes estos títulos con garantía
hipotecaria y yo sé que tienes por ahí
estos activos derivados y tú no me das
todas las cuentas claras muy pocas veces
vas a ver tanta transparencia como en
este ejemplo en la hoja de balance de un
banco en general nada más van a decir
que tienen un bonche de activos a los
cuales les llaman activos de nivel 3 y
esos son activos que en realidad la
administración de la empresa puede
decidir cuánto valen entonces si yo soy
la persona que prestó el dinero yo la
verdad diría sabes que yo había hundirse
al banco verster y se veía bastante
parecido a como tú te ves ahora
y pues también vi hundirse alimento
there si esa compañía se veía
exactamente igual a ti también y yo sólo
quiero que me pagues mi dinero de
regreso págame mis 10 billones ahorita
entonces si eres ese banco vas a buscar
a alguien más que te preste pero ahora
nadie quiere prestarle dinero porque les
da miedo y en una de esas alguien te
dice sabes que mira yo no te voy a dar
un préstamo pero te puedo dar un consejo
si tú crees que sus activos valen
suficiente porque no los vendes y
después vendes otros activos y pues ya
tienes tu dinero ni siquiera necesitas
el préstamo y el banco dice muy bien y
pues cuando termina el periodo del pre
de ese préstamo como no puede obtener
otros préstamos digamos que vende estos
entonces vende estos bonos corporativos
triple-a que son muy valiosos y obtiene
los 10 billones por ellos para pagar el
préstamo entonces te dan 10 billones de
pesos por él
y ahora tienes 10 billones de pesos en
efectivo
y con ellos puedes pagar el préstamo a
pagas los 10 billones
y este proceso que acabo de escribir se
llama de ese planteamiento que hoy voy a
hablar de esto en el próximo vídeo me lo
va a guardar para el próximo vídeo pero
básicamente lo que es es cuántos activos
tienes entre cuánto capital tienes si
tienes muchísimos activos controlados
por muy poquito capital
tienes una planteamiento inmenso ok
ahora pues osea reduje mis activos pero
no cambio en mi capital lo cual estuvo
muy bien no se puede pagar mi préstamo
así que eso me afectará en lo más mínimo
al capital pero bueno qué pasa cuando
cuando se acaba el periodo de este
préstamo y esta persona está muy
asustada dice elisa es que no estoy
preparado para renovar este préstamo y
sales a buscar a alguien que quiera
reemplazarlo pero todo el mundo está muy
asustado y entonces ok yo tengo estas
hipotecas comerciales y puedo venderlas
estos títulos son casi líquidos un
título es líquido si hay un mercado para
ellos y puedes encontrar a alguien que
los quiera comprar pero digamos que como
estabas en una situación muy complicada
y lo tenías que vender muy rápido y
todos están asustados entonces tuvo que
ser una venta de remate y solo obtuviste
9 billones por ellos valen 10 billones
pero cuando intentaste venderlos al
mercado solo pudiste 9 billones por
ellos
entonces obtienes 9 billones por ellos y
tienes que vender un billón de tus bonos
del gobierno para poder pagar los 10
millones del préstamo ver entonces ahora
se vuelve muy interesante mira el valor
libro de mi capital ha cambiado porque
tenía este activo que valía 10 billones
y lo vendí tuve que venderlo por 9
billones entonces bueno vamos a calcular
el valor libro del capital
ahora recuerda estos 4 billones son los
que la compañía dice que vale esto sede
o residenciales y 2.5 es lo que el
mercado dice entonces tengo 5 billones
ok 41 y de pasivos lo que tengo son nada
más tres billones entonces 5 menos 3 que
es igual a 2 eso es el capital que
tenemos ahora porque nuestro valor libre
el capital bajó de 3 billones a 2
billones pues porque yo creía que estas
hipotecas comerciales valían 10 billones
y como tuve que venderlas muy rápido
sólo pude venderlas por 9 billones
entonces perdí ahí un billón de pesos
por eso es que ahora el valor libro del
capital es 2 billones y observa esto el
valor libro de este cd o de título con
grande de hipotecaria o sea lo que el
banco dice que vale es 4 billones
y déjame lo escribo otra vez 4 billones
que es más grande que mi capital total
entonces si esto vale 0 tenemos un
capital negativo y si vale 2 billones en
lugar de 4 tenemos cero de capital
me estoy metido en situación muy
interesante y me pregunto qué es lo que
va a pasar cuando se acaba el periodo
del préstamo se vamos a explorar eso en
el próximo vídeo